terrible story out of Texas
this is a story that we've been tracking
I guess for years at this point the
story of Jeffrey younger you've probably
heard about Jeffrey younger
is this father who is trying to save his
son from being castrated and transd by
his lunatic ex-wife Jeffrey younger he's
in Texas we followed this story pretty
closely and the Texas Supreme Court has
just ruled against
Jeffrey younger preventing the chemical
castration of his son
so uh this means now that younger's
ex-wife
can take their son to California to have
him quote unquote medically transitioned
this mother is a complete Looney Tune
obviously doing very very evil things
she's a pediatrician
Jeff younger has accused this woman of
using their children to help advertise
her inclusive gender affirming practice
so surprise surprise This Woman's job is
to trans the kids and she decides one
day that her son is really a girl and
when when their son first started saying
this Jeff younger pulled out his phone
he said I want to document this for the
future when this becomes an inevitably
illegal matter son
why do you think you're a girl
you're a boy right no
I'm a girl who told you you're a girl
mommy
when did she tell you you were a girl I
love girls
oh I see so mommy told you you're a girl
uh-huh you know it was divorced
um in you know a few years ago
when my um when my child
um hit his third birthday and this
happened during the divorce
his third birthday he started telling me
that he was a girl
and I immediately I pulled out my video
and videotaped him and asked him why do
you think you're a girl you can see this
video saved james.com it's the first
time I heard about this okay what
happened was all of his authority
figures right his mom his sisters his
older sisters his teacher the policeman
at school a librarian the principals the
lunch lady all of his authority figures
were telling him he was a girl and I was
the only one and me and his priest were
the only one telling him that he was
born and he really just didn't believe
me
absolutely heartbreaking story your
heart breaks for this Dad Jeff younger
your heart breaks obviously for the kid
it's difficult not to be filled with a
righteous anger at this horrible mother
who is castrating her kid
everyone is viewing this as a story
about transgenderism the new gender
ideology or is a story about grooming or
sure it's all of those things
fundamentally this is a story about
divorce
when did all of this start to happen
when did the kid first say that he's a
girl when did the mother first start
moving to mess up his genitals and his
hormones
you heard Jeff younger say it said it
was during the divorce right during the
divorce coincidentally the kid starts to
go kind of crazy
or the mother drives the kid crazy many
such cases that's what happens why is
the kid in this terrible state that he's
in because Jeff younger has no say over
his kids life because they're divorced
and because our current divorce regime
allows crazy mothers to leave whenever
they want to again I don't know the
details of their divorce maybe he
instigated I don't know but when divorce
happens the fathers have very little say
in the raising of their kids
a lot of times conservatives
when we fight political battles we just
want to treat symptoms we want to treat
the immediate problem that we're looking
at right now and so in this case it's so
clear you want to treat the
transgenderism we got to stop the
transgenderism we got to stop the
grooming of kids yeah that's the
immediate problem but the cause of that
problem the sickness that is driving and
specific especially in this case
is divorce is the breakdown of the
family is the fact that even
conservatives now will not acknowledge
that men and women are different and
they have different roles and they are
complementary to one another
that's what marriage is
marriage as the Bedrock political
institution
is predicated on the fact that men and
women are different and complementary to
one another but there are many so-called
conservatives today who accept the the
absurd notion of gay marriage and they
do it because they have gay friends and
they don't want to seem mean and they
don't want to seem phobic but put all of
that aside I don't think it's mean or
phobic or anything like that to
acknowledge that marriage can only have
one meaning which is the the Perpetual
Union of a man and a woman for the good
of the spouses and the sake of the
generation and education of children if
we are to accept that men and women are
really different
the second we lose that
the second we stop defending marriage
the second forget about the gay marriage
redefinition thing for a second the
second that we Grant no fault divorce
the second that we grant that marriage
is just I don't know a consensual
temporary reunion of two people well
they titillate one another and then once
The Thrill Is Gone they leave and move
on and children be damned family be
damned the second and we admit that and
many conservatives admit that many
conservatives have no problem with lax
divorce laws many conservatives have no
problem redefining marriage many
conservatives have no problem with
transgenderism as long as you're 18 as
long as you make the decision to chop
off your genitals well if we're going to
grant that then even the conservatives
are not going to admit there's a
difference between men and women and and
then they're certainly not going to
admit that there's a difference in the
roles of men and women they're certainly
not going to admit that men have a
leadership role husbands have a
leadership role within the marriage to
be the head of One's Own household and
so the problem is just going to fester
and we can whine until we're blue in the
face about transgenderism and the child
abuse but you're not going to address
the root causes of of it so then what
are we even talking about
it's a it's a sad story and there are
going to be many many more sad stories
just like this
if we don't get serious about what is
allowing these things to happen okay we
should not be distracted by the the
crazy consequences of the the political
regime that we're living under we got to
get down to the problem when did all
this stuff start cropping up why did it
start cropping up it is a consequence of
the sexual Revolution it's a consequence
of the 1960s and a lot of Republicans
and conservatives are okay with that
it's why I can't really totally defend
Andrew Tate because Andrew Tate loves
the sexual Revolution Andrew Tate is
profited he's made millions and millions
of dollars off the sexual Revolution
okay good I guess you can buy some more
Bugattis
but but you're not going to conserve
anything of our traditional culture
you're not going to stand up for
civilization if you're doing that and
frankly the Republican establishment the
Rhino conservative squishy establishment
there there were basically all Andrew
Tate in this situation we've traded our
patrimony and our civilization for some
fancy Bugattis and some fun with with
loose Women on the side not great stuff
okay not great stuff at all the trans
bathroom issue
is almost certainly going to be headed
to the Supreme Court
this is a story not a lot of people have
talked about but the the 11th Circuit
Court of Appeals just held up in a 7-4
decision that the Saint Johns County
School Board policy barring girls who
identify as boys from using the high
school boys restroom does not violate
the student's constitutional right to
equal protection or Title IX
which is Title IX is the federal civil
rights law that bars discrimination
based on sex which the Supreme Court has
already said covers sexual orientation
gender identity so they've already
squished into the transgender camp on
that but the 11th Circuit Court of
Appeals decision
differs on the substance from a decision
two years ago by the fourth circuit
which struck down a similar policy in
Virginia so what that means is you've
now got a disagreement among the
circuits and disagreement among the
circuits is when you get a case to go up
to the Supreme Court so it seems very
likely to me that the Supreme Court not
only will be presented with this case
but will
will have to accept this case and so
that means that we will finally get
a clear
National decision on the transgender
bathroom issue which has been brewing
now for what eight or nine years I mean
this has been going on since the Obama
Administration you saw you saw this
first push to let boys into the girls
room and then Obama then there were laws
in North Carolina to stop the boys from
going to the girls room then Obama
couldn't handle that he said nope we're
gonna dog NAB it we're gonna let those
boys go into the girls room and so they
made a federal policy they they used the
Department of Education to try to force
boys into the girls room you you saw a
big political battle for years about
this
now it could possibly be resolved
some people are not going to be happy
about that
you're going to have the extreme
libertarian types say well the
government should have no say over this
come on the government we need to get
big government out of our bathrooms and
if if a school district wants boys to go
into the girls bathrooms why that's the
school district's decision and you do or
the really extreme Libertarians would
say use whatever bathroom you want you
know you're fully autonomous do whatever
you want with your own body
then you're going to see people who are
a little bit more conservative they're
going to say well
I don't want boys in the girls bathroom
but I don't want the federal government
making this decision I want it to be
left to the states
you saw a similar argument with regard
to abortion and marriage by the way
there are some people who believe that
we don't we shouldn't ban abortion
nationally we should just leave it to
the states
that's the kind of Middle Ground
conservative libertarian position or
with marriage well we shouldn't have a
national marriage definition we should
just leave it to the states if
Massachusetts wants to redefine marriage
to effectively abolish what marriage is
that's that's that's their right to do
so and if Texas and Tennessee want to
keep the traditional definition of
marriage well that's their right to do
so too and I just don't think that works
I think on a lot of issues that does
work okay I totally support subsidiarity
I think federalism can be a wonderful
thing and on all sorts of issues maybe
some gun laws maybe even drug laws in
some cases there's all sorts of
all sorts of cases in which the decision
should made be made at the most local
level possible
but when we get down to really
fundamental stuff like what is a man
what is a woman
I don't think you can leave that up to
the states Antonin Scalia made this
point actually on the question of gay
marriage he said I don't think you can
just leave it up to the States because
what happens then when a married couple
of two men leave Massachusetts and they
move to Tennessee is there marriage
quote unquote going to be recognized or
not you need uncertain really basic
things you need to come to some
conclusions if Society is going to do
anything at all
okay the principle of subsidiarity the
principle of Federalism is that you
always want questions to be answered at
the most local level possible well you
can't answer questions of what is a man
what is a woman what is marriage and
really basic stuff
at the county level here at the township
level
certain things really do have to be
answered
at the tippy top level that's why we
have a federal government that's why we
have a national capital
so I think I think we can win this
battle
I do think the Supreme Court reads
public opinion surveys I think the the
Supreme Court follows the election
returns I think it's very very clear
that the vast majority of Americans
oppose this transgender nonsense
especially as it pertains to kids
that may I I think so I don't know Neil
Gorsuch has been really kind of squishy
on on this issue but I think we could do
it
Republicans just need to cut out the you
do you kind of clap trap okay or on
McIntyre one of my favorite tweeters
has a line he articulates a
well-established principle and he
articulates it pretty clearly he has
said that the side that wants to win is
always going to defeat the side that
just wants to be left alone
really important principle for politics
the side that wants to win is always
going to defeat the side that just wants
to be left alone we should win this
decision it is absolutely unacceptable
to let boys use the girls bathroom
especially in high schools the daily
wire broke the story that probably
through Virginia to the Republicans in
the election of Glenn young which is
that Loudoun County schools because of
their stupid bathroom policy
allowed boys to go into the girls
bathroom and a girl was raped by a boy
in the girl's bathroom and then the
superintendent of the school covered it
up because it was clear that this policy
enabled this kind of behavior covered it
up move the kid to another school what
happened the kid did the same damn thing
at the other school this is unacceptable
it is it leads to terrible practical
outcomes and it is just
anthropologically absurd that boys can
really be girls and girls can really be
boys
we need to just say no to this and we
need to stand firm on that we have to
have to have the courage to wield the
force of our political order to say no
just say no other governments are doing
it even the Swiss are doing it is there
any nicer country than the Swiss
these guys are so go along to get along
they remain neutral in every single War
and the Swiss government has just
rejected transgender ideology
the Swiss Federal Council just said in
response to two proposals from
Parliament
quote the binary gender model is still
strongly anchored in Swiss Society the
social preconditions for the
introduction of a third gender or for a
general waiver of the gender entry in
the Civil registry currently are not
there
the government has to weigh in on
certain things if even the Swiss can do
it we should be able to do it too
France you know for goodness sakes the
French this was the last summer I think
Emmanuel macron leader of France came at
me said
wokism is a an American export
and we don't want it this wokism this
political correctness
this is France this is a pretty lib
Society they say but this woke thing all
this great we don't do that here that's
foreign that's something that the
American society is exporting around the
world and I think he was right about
that
you know the the silver lining in the
storm cloud of all this transgenderism
is I think that it is reminding
Republicans and conservatives who have
gone real squishy and become real
relativists in recent years who have who
have unfortunately
accepted the the worst premises of of
the Enlightenment of end of the last 300
years three four hundred years in
philosophical history to to ultimately
conclude that we really can't really
know anything at all and what is good
and what is bad and what is true most
false and maybe one man's good is
another man's bad and you do you and I
we can't you know all of this silly
nonsense
what the transgender issue I think is
showing Republicans is there are some
absolutes
there are some things that we can know
it's not all just relativism throw your
hands up in the air give everyone
maximal individual autonomy because we
can't really conclude anything at all on
certain things we actually can know okay
like when you start chopping off kids
genitals we know that's bad
and we can say it and we can stand up
for it and we have to stand up for that
but we're going to get into the
nitty-gritty of politics right now
that's on the member block you do not
want to miss it if you're not a member
click the link in the description and
join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]